we live on a planet of insects they make
up around 70 percent of all known
species on the earth and they're
combined biomass is 16 times that of
humans
300 million years ago giant dragonflies
with wingspans of 75 centimeters soared
amongst the tree ferns
nowadays insects are extraordinarily
diverse
existing in a bewildering array of
colors shapes and sizes
and they play a crucial role in life on
Earth their food for a great many
animals including most birds bats
lizards amphibians and freshwater fish
eighty percent of the world's wild plant
species depend on insects to pollinate
them as do three quarters of the plants
we grow for food it's no exaggeration to
say that without insects many of us
would starve
but many types of insects around the
world are in big trouble
although measuring insect populations is
complex there are worrying signs
a major 2020 study estimated that
globally land-dwelling insects are
declining by about nine percent per
decade
a German study found that the biomass of
flying insects on nature reserves fell
by an alarming 76 percent between 1989
and 2016.
in the United States populations of the
monarch butterfly are down 80 percent
this century
some species such as the comrade
Speckled Wood butterflies in the UK are
bucking the trend but the overall
Geographic range of butterflies in the
UK has contracted on average by 42
percent since 1976. invasive species
also take their toll rats ate the Saint
Helena giant earwig to Extinction and
have nearly exterminated the giant
wetter of New Zealand light pollution
also lures moths to bash themselves to
death and disrupts the timing of insect
life cycles
it also disorients some dung beetles who
navigate using the light of the Milky
Way
on top of all this insects now have to
cope with climate change
some adaptable insects such as
mosquitoes cockroaches and houseflies
will benefit from warmer temperatures
and more rain
most insects will suffer
Bumblebees are disappearing from the
southern edges of their range
overheating in their furry coats as the
climate warms
drys floods and forest fires will ravage
already depleted insect populations
in 1962 American biologist Rachel Carson
wrote Silent Spring warning that we were
doing terrible damage to our planet
She Wrote
man is a part of Nature and his war
against nature is inevitably a war
against himself
but what she witnessed was just the
beginning
since then insect-rich wildlife habitats
have been destroyed on a vast scale
soils have been degraded and rivers
choked with silt polluted or drained dry
farming so reliant on insects for
pollination is responsible for a large
part of their decline
an estimated 4 million tons of
pesticides are released into the global
environment every year
so what can we do if we want to protect
our insects the obvious place to start
is by rewilding our Gardens and
balconies inviting insects in by
planting wildflowers and Native shrubs
reducing lawn mowing and finding
alternatives to pesticides
but individual actions won't be enough
Imagine Green cities filled with trees
vegetable gardens ponds and unknown
verges all free from pesticides and
buzzing with life
a movement towards insect and
nature-friendly sustainable farming is
growing but it needs much more support
both from governments and consumers
it's not quite too late
most threatened insect species have not
yet gone extinct and could quickly
recover if protected
American biologist Paul Ehrlich likened
the loss of species to randomly popping
out rivets from the wing of an airplane
remove one or two and the plane will
probably be fine remove 10 or 20 or 50
and at some point there will be a
catastrophic failure and the plane will
fall from the sky
insects are the rivets that keep the
planet running
how many can be safely removed from the
plane before it crashes
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video